each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay good morning everyone it's my great
pleasure to introduce Tim Sherwood Tim
Sherwood is an assistant professor at UC
Santa Barbara he did his ph.d with Brad
Calder at UCSD and eat at the gate work
in architecture he meant at some point
which has used very widely in
architecture research to determine
representative simulation points with a
lot of work in prefetching and profiling
actually and now I'm finding out using a
lot of interesting work in security I
think he's not going to talk not much
about that but we can probably question
him about that too oh great I'm great
thank you well thanks for having me up
here yeah please ask me lots of
questions we can have a nice little
discussion here so today I want to talk
a bit about some of the work that we're
doing at Santa Barbara on streaming
introspection and so what I mean by that
well basically the problem that that
we're trying to address in my group at
large is that systems that we deal with
are getting so complex it really no one
understands what's going on anymore and
this is not just this is true across
many many different types of systems to
it's not just the one I'm going to talk
about today so one of the big problems
is it's a big problem is that this
there's so many layers of abstraction
right I mean that's not necessarily bad
to have abstraction but each person you
know making locally optimal decisions
may not always lead to a very stable
result right I mean that's not
necessarily what we want so abstractions
are necessary don't get me wrong I think
the idea of getting retractions not ever
going to happen but we need a way of
cutting through this abstraction right
so one great case example of this where
everyone you know in their local
abstraction thinks they know what's
going on is threads right i mean this is
a very very calm abstraction so you know
everyone thinks they're the one in
control of the threads right the
application developers think they're in
control threads known the runtime it
knows what's going on it it's an inch
arge of handling all the threads no no
the operating system runs under that
will let it be in charge maybe that's
running on a virtual machine and that's
really in charge of scheduling all the
threads
and of course you know now we have
multi-threaded hardware and the hardware
always thinks it knows what's best so
it'll actually be in charge of
scheduling all these threads on the
physical hardware all right well in fact
everyone thinks are in control in
reality no one is in control right
because all these people may or may not
be undoing all the hard work of the
people above them all right so just
being able to figure out what's going
wrong on a system where we have all
these different people thinking they're
in control you know that's that's the
heart of the first part of the problem
is just figuring admitting you have a
problem so this you know this this is a
big impediment to being able to do any
sort of analysis on any systems of any
complexity right so if you want to be
able to analyze the security of a sista
correctness of a system you want to be
able to debug performance problems and
systems you need to be able to have a
view that cuts across these layers of
abstraction all right so what we're
trying to do and the top the work on
presenting today is to rethink computing
right rethink computing as a whole the
whole from the Machine this from the
circuits up to architecture all the way
the software from a standpoint of
allowing visibility my allowing a system
to be able to analyze itself for one so
that means we want to be able to see
everything that's going on in the system
we want systems be accountable we want
to be able to control them more
efficiently we won't be able to adapt to
their behavior dynamically all right so
this is all quite hand wavy at this
point but it gets it does get a little
more concrete all right so how this fits
in with what I'm doing is you know this
is a larger this is a sub part of this
what we're trying to do is develop new
architectures and algorithms that really
enable high throughput analysis being
able to take a really complex system dig
through all the stuff that's going on
and figure out what's happening right
and that's actually a huge computational
problem in itself right so we tried to
develop new architectures and algorithms
that enable us to be able to analyze
systems at unprecedented speeds so the
problem kind of come we've seen that
this problem kind of comes in two
flavors right this high throughput
analysis problem
problem one is the needle in the
haystack problem right you have a ton of
data coming through and you want and you
care about that one event that's going
to make everything break for example
right so of all your network traffic
everything's fine except for that one
packet that makes your router died and
there are such packets so we want to be
able to find that right we want to
always be able to find that so so we
need new mechanisms for being able to
search and find those needles in a
haystack so we've been developing you
know these really high throughput graph
algorithms and architectures for doing
just that the other type of problem so
maybe we can find the needle in a sec is
you just have a lot of hay right you
need to figure out from all the
different pieces of hay straw you know
what is the shape of this hate back we
want to quantify the haystack all right
a needle needle at a time as it were so
here we need to be able to take low
level events right and aggregate them
together and to put together a high
level picture of actually what's
happening and this is more what I'm
talking about today the second type of
problem right so why is this hard why
you know we have all this data why is it
going to be what's so hard about putting
it together and building an accurate
picture of the entire system well the
problem is data right we have tons of it
all right processors are executing
billions of instructions per second all
right networks are processing billions
of bytes per second all right and we
won't be able to look at all that and be
able to say something about you know a
system that's that's generating that all
right so we can't just take this data
dump it to a trace and then analyze it
later necessarily you know and we don't
necessarily want to rely on sampling
because we might miss those needles so
on so what we want to have smarter
techniques that are going to allow us to
to really analyze systems at their full
speed all right so
so my lab UCSB we basically approach
this problem across pretty much every
level of modern computing systems right
from you know we do high-throughput
analysis to enable to do basically
software profiling adaptation and
adaptation and optimization right so and
that's really what I may be talking
about today right but these problems
find themselves lots of other places
right so building a high-throughput
intrusion detection device is a
high-throughput analysis problem right
so we need how through analysis
architectures for that being able to
figure out what's going on as a system
of the whole at the server farm and
network layer when you have a large
distributed a puke late application you
know and my application doesn't live on
a single machine anymore it lives in the
network and the machine so now I need
another thing to be able to do the
analysis there all right actually what
happens inside of modern router is a
high-throughput analysis problem right
basically routers analyze the flow of
traffic and make decisions accordingly
right load balancing it's a big one just
routing is a high-throughput analysis
problem right so but there's more so we
also do it you know each one of these is
kind of an ongoing project at UCSB
publications you know building modern
software-defined wireless is a
high-throughput analysis problem modern
wireless devices learn and adapt to the
wireless channel they are involved in
based on the reflections and the multi
calves that a given signal can take so
it's a high-throughput analysis problem
I need a but will quantify that wireless
channel to be able to send data at high
throughput we also work on
high-throughput MEMS device controllers
right people are in mechanical
engineering and building these devices
that operate on the microscale you know
they do mechanical things but they can't
they can build them they can fabricate
them they can hook them up to a machine
that and show that they might work but
they have no way to control them so
another control I threw for them
analysis problem
and it's awesome we also do some work on
a reconfigurable security in fpgas which
also fits into this analyzing what
hardware is actually doing is execute
and so we run quite a gamut from
circuits all the way up to systems okay
so but for this talk that's my my whole
should be about my lab we're going to
talk to concentrate more on just what's
going on within a processor right so
what's the main idea here well the main
idea is that these complex interactions
happen across levels of abstraction
right so we need to be able to cut
through these figure out what's going
out the first requirement that we have
is just being able to see everything you
know before we can even do any analysis
we need to be able to just see
everything that's happening that's the
first analysis technique is going to be
predicated on the build on that ability
right so and we think that the hardware
software boundary doing things of
architecture level you know potentially
even in hardware it gives you a really
unique perspective in that everything is
built on top of that all right so you
can see at least within a given
processor you can see everything above
it right and we can take little vents
from there and grow them parse them
together into a high level picture of
what's happening so all right so enough
hand waving what am I gonna talk about
today so really two parts first part is
just is discussing how we're actually
going to get our hands on the data we
need to do a software analysis at full
execution ranked right and so there's
some circuit and architecture techniques
for doing that and it's kind of there's
some interesting trends going on in
architecture to which I'll talk about
that make this particularly possible the
other half of this is all right now I
have a ton of data what can I start to
do with it so we're going to start
talking about how to manage data at that
rate and be able to do queries on it and
so on actually some analysis
architectures so we don't want to choke
on all the day we're going to generate
data execution rain we don't want to
then choke on it
alright so so you know so now we want to
build some analysis we want to build
some software analysis routine right we
have some program we want to analyze it
for performance or we want to be able to
say something about security of that you
know executing application so what do we
want from the hardware all right what
information do we need from the harbor
well that's pretty simple we want
everything right so you know is this
absurd perhaps i'm not sure but you know
let's maybe let's put together a
shopping list of what we'd actually need
if we wanted everything right well we're
going to need 32-bit memory addresses
for every single loads and store right
we're going to need the 32-bit memory
values from every load in store this is
a if you're a 32-bit architecture can
get 64 obviously if it's a 64-bit
architecture for every instruction
executed you're going to need the opcode
of that instruction right you're going
to need which registers are being
accessed write the names of the
registers you're going to want to the
values of the registers that are being
accessed all right because you're going
to want to know lots of different status
things right was this instruction a
cache hit was this instruction a branch
misprediction so on so forth there's a
lot of different stuff right and I need
all this per instruction per cycle right
so if I have a machine that executes
with three instructions per cycle I'm
going to need three times that and if I
have a multi-core machine it gets even
more fun say four cores I haven't four
times that right so let's add it up it
comes out to eighteen ninety two bits
per cycle which if you convert it into
unity or more familiar with is about a
terabyte per second at for gain hurts so
that's um that's a lot of data alright
that's a lot of data but we we
potentially if we want to build
something that's actually general
purpose we want to build some system
that can do any analysis we might come
up with we're going to need at least
this probably going to be more than this
so you know are we totally hosed or
can't yeah please
yeah we're going to keep this data I
mean you are you analyzing in real time
or give up for three days or so what we
try to do on the same time to talk about
we want to do it all streaming so we
want to essentially keep only a small
amount of data and then we're just gonna
straight pipe this step through and do
do our all our announces sort of online
so yeah we don't want to build a big
trace and go back and mine it later a
terabyte a second it's hard to build a
full trace so all right so that's what
we want right so now why can't you know
so what's the problem well well actually
before I get to what's problem so what
would that really entail right so here's
a floor plan of a p4 right so that data
that I need is in here right it just
happens to be that it's all over all
right there's no single place where I
can get all this data from I need to go
to the caches I need to go a register
file need to go to the decode so on and
so forth so I need to get all this
information from all over the chip
alright so so that's a that's a big pain
so so that's what we want we want all
the data from everyone the chip every
cycle so why can't we have it you know
what's the problem figure everything is
on chip right we'll just route all those
wires to some place we'll put a little
analysis engine there and everything
will be happy all right well this inner
connect these wires these blue parts
they're not free sadly so why is that
well I'm going to have to physically run
a wire from one end of my trip to my up
to the other end of my chip why is that
so bad well because I can't just run a
wire from one end of the trip to the
other in the chick what I need to do is
I need to buffer that wire so for
example optimal buffer length for a wire
is 285 microns which means i need to
divide these wires up into little chunks
that are a 285 microns across all right
so if you do the numbers for this for
these wires that's about 20,000 buffers
right the buffer is a small thing what's
so hard well each of those buffers see
oops okay each one of those buffers
I'll talk I'll show you a circuit
diagram later but each one of those
buffers requires that we take this wire
which is at the top level of metal of my
chip right and then route it down
through all these different levels of
mental to the silicon which is eight
layers below me right go through one
inverter right and they're at it all the
way back up so the top level of silicon
game right why is that a pain it's a
pain because well first of all now I
have all this I have to reserve space
through this whole column my chip to get
down just looking and all the way back
up again that's a big pain another big
pain is that I need to coordinate with
everyone who's designing this chip where
those buffers are going to go right so
now so typically the way you want to
design these things in a modular fashion
right someone's in charge of the energy
Direction execution stuff someone's in
charge of retire so on so forth right
now all these people have to be tightly
coordinated tisket to figure out where
they're actually gonna put these buffers
so this is why people like Intel really
don't want to do this is a huge pain not
only that this is just talking about the
wires right I mean that's not even
mentioning what we're going to have to
do to do the analysis that analysis the
processing we're going to want to be
able to do it a terabyte second is
non-trivial so you know putting
something on this chip that's capable of
dealing with that much data is going to
cost something it's going to cause
something not only just an area but it's
also going to suck down heat for example
you know Intel very worried about the
cost of one of their systems right when
they're done in the total budget for
example the total budget that they have
for cooling is fifteen dollars alright
you cannot spend more than fifteen
dollars on cooling a processor right
their technique there's technologies out
there that are cool pretty much anything
they cool jet engines nope those have a
up much higher thermal density than a
processor right but they can't do that
for fifteen dollars so I mean there are
some serious market issues here at work
alright so this so here's we get to the
fundamental problem right what we need
we want something as developers you know
even if all the software developers
ganged up right and said we demand this
you know Intel really still wouldn't
care because we're such a small part of
their market right were the people using
who want this right not uh you know not
the other people who are on developers
right and there's a lot more of them so
so are we just now are we just totally
in trouble i'm not sure i don't think so
i think what we can do we can have our
cake and eat it too right we want it we
need to have a way to provide this cheap
high margin a cheap or higher margin
hardware to the masses right basically
we don't want to add cost to into the
one of those processors that's not an
acceptable thing to do so yeah we don't
want to have to have you know my grandma
paying for some hardware that only
developers use I my grandma is not a
software developer all right but at the
same time we need to get this analysis
that this the ability to powerful
analysis that developers really demand
okay so the way we think we can do this
is to provide a sort of snap-on ability
right basically you just want to be able
to clip on something that does an alice
is right and we'll just clip that on to
the systems that need it so we'll build
our what we're going to propose to do is
take our analysis engine build it as a
separate chip right and then we're going
to I'm going to show you a way that that
may be able to be hooked on to an
existing system and while only going to
hook it onto the developer systems the
other people get the cheap version
developers get the the expensive version
with the thing put on and maybe you know
maybe you can't cool it for fifteen
dollars maybe you have to spend a
hundred dollars to cool that you know so
we spend an extra hundred dollars on a
machine that we're going to use to debug
our programs you know it really is that
going to sink us know so we need to
separate these two if we want to get the
functionality we demand so the reedy
integration is interesting circuit
packaging dome technology that's being
developed which offers the potential to
be able to actually do make this happen
right so I'm going to tell you a bit
about 3d integration basically 3d
integration
takes multiple dies slaps them together
connects them up and then put some in a
single package all right so this is this
is kind of how it works at a very high
level so we start with a standard
silicon substrate just you know like you
build a processor right you have an
active layer on top this is where all
our transistors live on this top plane
just they just live on the very top of
the silicon right and then a mono
processor has a bunch of metal wire
interconnect right modern chips have
like eight to ten layers of interconnect
I just middle on top of them all right
so that constitute the normal processor
right what we want is to take another
chip right we're going to slap it on top
right and then we're going to have
another you know this other trip has its
own active layer on the top of the
silicon right so now that's great except
they can't talk so we need to have a way
for those two to communicate so the one
on the top will be whatever Hardware
performance monitor whatever you want
call it you know the analysis engine so
how do they going to talk well there's
many different technologies for this but
the one that we consider and then once I
think industry is putting the most money
behind is this idea of 3d vias basically
vertical V is that what you do is you
take this chip the second die right you
stack it on top right you fuse them
together and then you etch holes through
all the way through this piece of
silicon and then basically dumped metal
in so that it connects to the top loader
metal of this next guy it's kind of cool
stuff in fact you know they think that
they can stack maybe eight of these guys
on top of one another all right so these
are three DB is in the you know so one
question is you know all right so really
how big can I make these things well
each one of these can be about 20
microns outside not as small as not the
smallest as the metal pitch you know
it's may be a factor of a hundred times
bigger than these wires but still it's
pretty darn small 20 microns not be
right so now we just sell this bottom
part here
right we'll select all the people who
aren't developers and they get the nice
cheap hardware and then first developers
will will get the full stack right with
our extra snap-on analysis all right so
is this just totally science fiction may
be all right there are no production
devices which are built using this
technology yet but Intel an IBM both
invest heavily in 3d integration
technology and they put a lot of money
into this one and there you know already
developed trying to develop new
architectures that exploit 3d technology
so there and there are many many
different types of three prototypes that
have been demonstrated so a one question
is so Intel for example they wants you
just for performance reasons be able to
take a processor slap a cash on top
right so if you're already going to slap
a cash on top what's the big deal we'll
just slap another analysis engine on top
of that right alright so yes these large
server farms things go wrong in that do
you think that where do you think that
would fall in your economic model it
seems like you would need your analysis
framework you you've got 20,000 machines
and somewhere something is causing
something disruptive your server network
server party you need to figure out what
is going on here so which one am I going
to define that's a good question so we
so we actually this work we're only
supposing that you do it for you know
development systems not for not for
using it for production sort of
debugging although you're absolutely
right you would like to be able to do
that so and I don't know the answer to
answer that question honestly although
we do a lot of we do a lot of system
level stuff sort of in the network and
so I'm not there's there's there's a lot
of we can talk about this more that'd be
great okay yeah
traditional flip-chip just going to get
to depends if you just want one layer if
you want eight layers of cash you can't
do flip chip and you can also
potentially do this flip chip to our
analysis section so yeah then the cost
comparison seems a date not one question
my ask is is 3d cheaper than just making
bigger guys and you spread the available
are dumped your buffers in between
potentially I mean yeah being that no
one's even built a production line of
packaging it's really hard to estimate
the cost so and you know they haven't
even decided on a finalized what if what
the 3d RK what the 3d best 3d technology
is so it's very much an active ongoing
area in fact here I'll show you a couple
of the leading candidates right so one
you can do flip chip you can also do
which basically flip chip for the other
people is you basically just take the
active layers of two guys in the Sam gem
like that bond them together you can
also do wire bonded multi-chip modules
where you just take these different diet
and it basically build wires that just
go between the dies now that one you can
do today but there's also more
interesting ones such as contact list
integration right where instead of using
a physical wire if it's go die die you
use inductive interconnect right or use
a capacitive interconnect right one
inductor draws another inductor and you
can sense that or one capacitor plate
drives other passive plate and you can
sense that in fact people built versions
where you can use inductance to sort of
to align the dies so that you just slap
it on top of the inductors align the die
and its use this communication also it's
printing so but for this research you
know we have to pick a technology to do
just so we can have a graph right so
what we are considering is this work
Banerjee on building these dies like I
said we're
we actually take one active layer they
put another chunk of silicon on top they
they eventually they take another chunk
of silicon they fabricate all the sort
of the circuitry for that for that
second die right then they take that
diet and they grind it down literally
with a polishing to a very very thin
layer right about 50 microns and then
they stick it on top of the first die
and then they etch these these are these
vertical vs through it all right so we
constrain this one so our goal I mean
what we think is that we're not going to
be for free right but hopefully we can
make it for pretty darn cheap so cheap
that it's hard for people say no to it
right one of the reasons is that we only
need vias as taps right so one of the
things is we have to route our signals
from this active layer up through the up
through the metal layers to the top
level of a layer of metal so that we can
send it up to the next chip right but
usually the signals you want to look at
like address bits all right our tend to
be global so we're not going to need
20,000 buffers in order to do and route
these things all across the chip we only
need one buffer per bit essentially to
write it straight up requires no
coordination between the different you
know groups all you have to do is put a
basically a post that goes straight up
that we can then I truck signals out
later all right so so what are the four
kind of possibilities here well one
possibility is base case right no one
listens to me you step right now and
they you know that we just can continue
on going without any analysis engine and
you know everything is basically p for
option two we take that Hardware
introspection stuff that we want to be
able to do we integrate it on the chip
alright we actually just save space for
route the wires all the way across to
some centralized analysis place and
we'll just do that option three is we
have some stacked we have we basically
have a system with to stack layers of
silicon we used for analysis
right the version we sell double and
then we have won this just stubs right
so the stubs is the one we're going to
sell to point here boss this is the this
just has the V is that go up to the top
but no extra chip bonded to the top tech
clear all right so you can quantify I
mean you can read our asphalt paper and
learn all kinds of interesting numbers
and then we make up and because no one's
doing this right now the you know so you
can see here this is our estimate of how
much increases you're going to have an
area just due to routing that
interconnect all right not not from the
actual analysis engine even of adding
extra harder right even if we could pay
it made a way to build that analysis
hardware infinitely small you still have
to pay this much just to get the data to
it alright so for for integrated so this
is all normalized so zero would be base
right and then for our integrated one
we're going to need a whole bunch of
metal right and then we're going to need
even a bunch of area for our active
layers then for our stack version all
right we just need we're just going to
need a little bit of a little bit of
active basically just the buffers rate
to send the data straight up on the
first level right then on the second
level where the analysis engine is we're
going to need to have then we're going
to have to route all that stuff around
right so we're going to pay coughs there
so but actually even there the cost is
less because we can put the nail sis
engine on top of the thing we want to
measure rather than to the side and then
the stubs is basically just how much
those stuffs cost right so we also have
an X we have a power analysis that shows
the increase in power of doing all these
different techniques just for the just
for their routing now I'm gonna worry
about the analysis ok so where are we
now right so we've we've done some work
you publish this paper and ass boss but
there's a lot of open questions that we
don't have answers to yet you know and I
think there's some interesting
discussion here hopefully so one big
question is all right so I could build a
let's say wildest dreams I can build you
hi throop analysis engine what does that
else's and you're going to do right how
come how can I for one care you know
characterize how good of a job that's
doing right there's no real set of
benchmarks for doing program analysis
you know how a second problem is all
right so now how am I going to prototype
this system you know am I stuck to a
might not gonna be able do any
interesting architecture work or
software development work or analysis
work until I actually have 3d this 3d
chip from Intel I hope not so actually
we have an answer to this one which is
we build a prototype but that prototype
basically runs on an FPGA right so it we
take the data we take programs it
doesn't run at full speed right we take
programs we run them in Val grind we
instrument them in Bal grind we take
those we cut at basically all we have to
do is insert instrumentations we insert
stores right those stores then go to
write to memory and then our FPGA
analysis board sucks the analysis data
out of memory with DMA right and then it
crunches whatever numbers we want to do
so we can actually take an implement an
analysis architecture run software on it
and you know run you know Mozilla or
whatever we want through Internet
Explorer through through our analysis
framework so it allows us to really
start to have some notion of what we're
actually I what to do next all right so
another big question is you know what's
all right so what's a suitable
architecture for an analysis engine what
is it even doing it's doing high
throughput analysis which is certainly
not what a p4 is built to do all right a
p4 is built to do really low latency you
know things with very low latency so we
just have data streaming through this
thing at incredibly high rates the
architecture you want to build for that
there isn't an architecture that it's
built for that basically maybe the
terror then how this is actually another
area that I think there's a lot of
interesting interaction with especially
in terms of what the compiler group is a
big question we have is how we can
actually program at least analysis
engines so we're streaming data through
we're going to need some way of
describing
what program analysis is in a formal way
and there's some people have done work
on event grammar so i'm not sure if
familiar of that but we think that's
promising there so this is this is the
one that excites me most okay which is
so now I have you know I have this
device they allow you to do program
analysis it and precedent rates what new
stuff can we do with it now all the
analysis people I talk to you know I
when I pose this question it takes a
long time to start thinking that way
right because they're let all their work
is you know we'll take we'll do
everything we can sophomore but you know
no one's going to accept a publication
if it has ten percent overhead right or
maybe 2x overhead right but now we can
take things that used to be 1000 x slow
down and run them execution right we
think question yeah so here you are very
lowest level gathering this streaming
information what about supplementing
that with information from higher levels
definitely yeah we really need to do
that so we're just starting from the
bottom and working out we're going to
try to work our way up from the bottom
so I don't have an answer to that I
think other than we need to do that yes
yeah sure definitely that's so you just
answered my last question what am I
going to talk about for the next half of
the talk thank you so that's it that's
exactly right and we think there's a lot
of potential for sort of for Derek all
its energy I better not between between
a that field and our feet interview
architecture so what are we going to do
with all the data so let's change gears
now from IC design to a more algorithm
more program analysis standpoint right
so let's just take let's see what we can
do right with some of these are now
these streaming analysis algorithms so
let's just start with like the most
fundamental ability we want to have in
any sort of analysis is just the ability
to count events
right without being able to do that it's
gonna be hard to do much of anything so
so those events could be basic blocks it
can be a load of you know figure out
load value distribution that could be
figure out you know all the load address
is where all the load instructions are
all the loads attractions i miss you
know all these basic things narrow with
operations so the challenge is that you
have these huge complex programs we have
analysis engine with a limited amount of
storage very small amount storage and we
want to do our analysis at runtime
online all right so well just to make
this second half concrete let's consider
let's consider code profiling as an
example okay it's easier to talk with in
a real example so it's a very simple
example but it works nicely so let's
consider co profiling right so we have
our program here which call an assembly
sure you recognize it now let's just
consider this program frankly right as a
list of basic blocks all right so each
one of these boxes it's a basic block
now you know each basic block execute
some number of times right so basically
some of these blocks are hot and some
are not and so we want to figure out
which of the hot ones and which ones
aren't so two questions right that
answering that requires answering two
questions first of all where are the hot
regions and second of all how hot are
they okay so and we want to be able to
do this all at runtime nothing i'm
asleep so let's start with the simple
approaches see how they break and we'll
build up to what we actually propose so
the simplest account this the simplest
to describe the hardest build is to use
an infinite number of counters right so
we'll assign one counter to one basic
block right so that kept the coverage is
an important point the coverage of this
counter is one basic block right it's
just counting for that one basic block
and then we'll just take that basic
block and we're we take that counter up
Canada infinite number of times
everything is easy all right so we get
so what's nice about this we have an
basic blocks we have encounters so we
get very high coverage our entire
program is covered I
because I've infinite number of those
counters and i am very high precision
meaning that i know precisely how many
times each basic block executed right so
that's about as good as we could hope to
do problems course is fitting that on a
chip right or in memory need them so are
one of our ideas is that well you know
not all basic blocks are is important as
others and maybe what we can do is look
at basic blocks we can group them based
on how important they are and count them
that way I didn't explain that very well
but you'll see so let's just constrain
this little bit let's limit the number
of counters we have all right so option
one will just apply we have fixed number
of counters counters and we'll just
apply them right here it might not be
the best job but it's a pretty good job
right I know now precisely how hot each
of those basic blocks are that is very
hot that's great so I got high precision
for the for the hot spots in it but I
have very low coverage i only know
specifically about one part of the
program right so it's great in that case
but it's bad in this case right if i
accidentally picked to look at these
basic blocks which are basically never
executed I learn a lot less about the
program alright so I have low coverage
especially of those those regions which
I care most about ok yeah yeah you guys
figure that out so I well maybe what we
should do is distribute the basic blocks
among the counters I'll show you all
right so here's another negative
approach right we'll just have a counter
which that countered tracks the count of
all these basic blocks right I know
nothing about any one basic block in
that group but I know precisely how many
times if I sup basically something more
time as those based boss that's what I
know all right so now I can just take my
k counters and I can cover the entire
program using that way that's great
right now I have high coverage but I low
precision
I know I don't know what's going on a
very low level so good problem of course
is that one these basic block but one of
these counters and now associate with a
very large number of basic blocks and
you know for the hot regions I really
care right so I only know I only have
the average behavior a very high level
so let's see i'll skip this related work
you can read my paper if you want it
really work but so what we want to
provide is high coverage high precision
on the things that need precision with a
fixed limited number of counters and we
want to do it all in a streaming online
fashion no two passes all one pass
that's what we try to do so I'm the
ideal case you know what do we want what
do we want to get out of this system
well for the hottest region so we want
to have counters tightly associated with
each of those basic blocks right and
then we want to have other counters
which cover other regions of the program
with precision which is proportional to
how hot they are you know so I know a
lot about the things which are most
important and less about the things
which are less important seems like a
good way to use my resources so we can
you get high coverage we have lower
precision but we have precision rate
where we need it now the challenge of
course is discovering how discovering
what to count and with what precision
you should count each of those basic
blocks all right so if I come up with a
good approach right and ideal profiler
then it's going to make really great
decisions you know I'm going to know
exactly what to profile with how much
precision right at the beginning right
but the problem is that we don't know
which ones to count until we actually
execute all right so we have this
problem we have the problem of
identifying ranges you figure out what's
coming second and actually doing the
counting right we want to identify the
ranges but we need to know what the
counselor before you can pick the ranges
but we need to know what ranges are
before we can start counting them all
right so which one we do first and what
order and so on well we try to solve
both together and a unified scheme
alright so this idea of range adaptive
profiling which my student shot she
presented it cgo 2006 solves exactly's
problem by doing it an online by
figuring out the ranges online a dynamic
manner with some nice proof guarantee
use of that off should work so how does
it what does it do so in the initial
case we just have one counter okay
that's easy and that counter covers the
entire program how many instructions are
being executed apart now what happens is
eventually this counter will become hot
right we're actually going to build a
tree all right what have we kind of
think these these nodes kind of grow
grow full they go ripe until the point
that we need to split them burst them
apart right so after we realize that
this is hot and of course it will
because it covers everything then we
split it apart into two counters right
now each one of these counters covers
some the top half of the program in the
bottom half of the program so and we
just apply this recursive at any time a
counter becomes hot right so now left
counter on the top is hot we split it
it's great right we keep doing this well
we end up with is counters right applied
to the hot the they're going to be
applied with the most precision to the
hottest regions right but we're still
going to have full coverage of the
program and we're still actually going
to count every single event all right
every event that happens every base bugs
as excuse get counted someplace it just
happens to be that it's counted with a
different different precision based on
how important it is close to each other
it was a great question so I'll get to
that one second so uh yeah all right
said this all right so now one more
slide that off so the advantage of this
is actually our final technique is that
we have a streaming one path we're going
to wear have a streaming one path method
to do this all hierarchically right to
hire classical my events and we have
some night we can prove some nice
theoretical balance about it like that
you can fix the number of counters and
get provable goodness and error you
bound your error which is nice it's not
a sampling approach we provide precision
on the hottest regions yeah all right I
set all this out of order and you can
use this to do all kinds of different
profiling on code values load addresses
and we explore a bunch of these
different ones all right but here's the
tricky parts right so the tricky part
first tricky part is all right when do I
split how do I know when a split the
second trick part is when do I know when
to unsplit or merge all right because
you have to do with both of those so
when do I split well figuring out when
you split is pretty easy actually did
you just keep a track of how big the
stream is up to the point you've seen it
all right you just have a counter it
tracks how many of events total you've
seen and then if it's above some
proportion of that if I've given notice
above some proportion of that then you
split it it's very it's trivial right
but with that you can actually end up in
the merging you can actually bound or
thats how you guy couldn't split
thresholds just and it's a function of
the height of the tree also so now we
have this nice way of doing adaptive
precision right yeah time frame to where
you clear the map doors because you've
been running for a whole day and
something is really hot three minutes
you're going to miss it uh oh that is
true I mean so this is so this provides
an overview of how hot things are as a
proportion of the entire execution or
there's a the high or whatever higher
level switch you want to be able to
say all right so it says for a given
continuous region of time you know what
estimate the percentage hotness of all
the things during that period of time so
you're right if something is just hot
for three minutes we and it does if it
doesn't account for a significant
portion of the total we won't see that
necessarily but if but if it's just
let's say let's consider the other way
around right let's consider that you
program starts up doing something
totally unimportant and you start
profiling with very high precision that
unimportant stuff and then of course
when it gets to the good stuff you're
not looking right you want to avoid that
we can solve that problem you run
forever as long as the program runs
that's what we do yeah so but you can
certainly mean that be a high level
thing if you want to be able to target a
specific specific region there's no
there's no reason you can so did I
answer your questions official i'm not
sure just seems like you know there are
some performance problems where people
could be suffering for an hour with some
server app or something and you're
sampling for three days and it doesn't
show this hot oh that's definitely true
yeah that's that's right so what you're
kind of saying those you want to be able
to weigh the more recent information
more heavily perhaps so that there are
also sort of other streaming algorithms
work on that try to do this but this one
is not this this one assumes they're all
sort of uniform importance and we didn't
this is not this is by the way it's not
a solution to profiling as a whole
problem right this is a nice this is a
very useful mechanism from which you can
build profiles all right so let's
consider a temporary hot example right
so we start up the program's doing
something like you know initializing all
to raise you think and you know you're
adapting so you say well I better study
that very carefully all right so you
build this huge tree to precisely
quantify that then turns out that you
know who cares about initializing your
arrays because tears that were the
actual computations happening right so
now you have to build this whole that's
know our hot yet to build this whole
other tree
now adaptively sense that right well
that's not good because now if I always
did that there's no way I could ever
bound the number of counters I need
right so I need to be able to unsplit
all right so this part is good you know
this part I don't need it it's bad
pretty simplistic I guess but um yeah we
want to merge those back together so
what we do is we actually recursively
emerge and doing merges is a lot more
complicated actually so we emerge we
basically just take these data and we're
going to add those together into this
data although you can use any function
you want really so we always keep we
never lose a single count right the only
thing we do is mess with the precision
of that count all right so all we do is
we see that each one of these is now no
longer hot according to some proportion
of the entire string and we just put
them back together okay so yeah I sell
this okay so here's the problem with
merges right so merges are trickier
because a split happens you a split
always happens where your data is going
right so if I have some piece of data
that I want to count all right it goes
it lanes in some node right and now that
data makes that node too heavy and I
have to split it right but I already
know which no time considering because I
just my data just went there that
property doesn't hold for merchants
right in fact the exact opposite holds
you know I'm making something hot over
here this guy over here which I haven't
heard from for a long time is now cold
and needs to be merged so how do I find
that so the original algorithms actually
every cycle would go through and count
all the figure out all the possibilities
for merging or they had some crazy data
structures and and it made it really
great a big o notation to do that but
when you try to build it it hurts a lot
so instead we actually extend this
algorithm and we actually show that you
really only need to do an exponentially
infrequent number of
urges we just batch them together
because the tree grows with as the tree
grows the split the split threshold
changes dynamically as the program
executes so it becomes harder and harder
for splits to pack up on you alright so
you can actually bound the number of
split says as some curve right a
logarithmic curve actually alright so
you know that it can't grow faster than
logarithmically with the size that
you've seen so we can just batch we can
just do these mergers in batch mode and
the longer we execute the you know every
time I execute then I can wait another
two times as long as I waited last time
to do another set of mergers and then we
just do all the merchants at once we
just do one whole pass over the whole
tree do all the mergers and then we know
we're in a middle minimal emerged stay
at that point so this is that's actual
data from GCC doing this on basic blocks
another thing you can optimize is okay
all the examples I show nice and easy
because we split by two right do you
really want to split by two or do you
wanna split by four or do you want to
split by eight or do you want to split
based on some semantics of the program
that's it more interesting thing to do
we have done that yet but um you know so
for us just from a hardware perspective
bestest foot by four turns out alright
so let's see click just a result or two
I'm almost done so at a high level so
how you know how well is this technique
work right so you know we did a bunch of
work to track quantify how good of a job
this doesn't pro fine actually that's a
hard thing to do because we don't count
in a way that most people traditionally
count we do this adaptive precision
stuff and so how do you quantify how bad
it is that you now only know at a high
level you know what happened how do you
quantify the the badness of having less
precision so look there's a whole
discussion the paper of how we do that I
don't have time for here but you know on
average we can see that air haha let's
keep that
oops sorry that you know we find that
even if we take some really pessimistic
assumptions about how the data is
distributed we still have an error of
less than 2% right for just having and
this is well so just an average error of
two percent so we have a two percent
error but how much does it cost us well
really that we just have to be able to
track on average around 150 notes to get
that kind of error on the basic blocks
so that's 150 nodes is not not very many
at all right you can easily build that
into hardware in fact we have built a
prototype in hardware okay there's a lot
more results than paper oops so we may
have a software implementation of all
this algorithm stuff that it runs pretty
darn fast I think you just it's really
simple API just there's data structure
you knit you just add points into it
finalized it's all free it's all
available on the web page you know you
feel free to play with it but it's all
good to have a software approach but now
we have this thing with the little blue
light we want to be able to run rap on
this all right so what can we do well we
build a hardware version of it so this
is our hardware profiling engine so our
hope our web profile engine if you
really think about what rap is doing you
can break it down into a pipeline and
each of those pipelines is actually
fairly simple straightforward you know
so straightforward then an undergrad can
build it I know because I have proof of
that because one day so we we basically
just take we need to have some buffer at
the front where we take all our values
whatever we want to profile IP addresses
pcs and the number of times that they or
maybe some quantity right we actually we
actually take that buffer and we
compress it to make it run faster no one
um you can ask me about that later if
you really care all right so then the
first problem we have is actually all
right we have this big tree data
structure right we need to find where my
node is in this tree well it seems like
not something that you could design
hardware for very easily well really the
tree is not that big I 150 entries you
can build a cat tcam that's thousands of
entries no problem right and a tee cam
if you use it the right way essentially
does a fully peril tree search all right
so so what we do is so tcam essentially
just associate some bits with some it
has some bits and some wild card and
then you basically say you drive on this
line what you're looking for and then
the person that actually has that that
matches that then they just you know
they say I think I'm a match I think I'm
imagined I would think I'm a match right
so 00 star 0000 star and all 0 is 10 *
they all match right and those will
correspond to the nodes and the trees
which are serve all the parents of where
of what I'm looking for so make sense
then I just have to find the longest
match which is basically just an arbiter
that's easy to build hardware and then
now I know exactly which one I want then
I just have to look up in a table right
now I have now that I know where the
note is that I'm trying to update I just
have to increment its counter so there's
a little piece of memory and then you
have to have some control logic
basically which basically makes this
pipe on work you can stop the thing and
do merges and and actually can do splits
with with no stalls that's the one
tricky part I'm being able to do splits
so just although figuring out if you
need to do splits actually really easy
you just check if it's above some
threshold and then you just have to
insert that split back in as you go all
right so where we go from here so now we
have a way of analyzing analyzing ray of
basic blocks you know great I want to be
able to do more than that alright so the
next the next logical step or we're
trying to take this is to is to build
something which can do
multi-dimensional profiling range
adaptively all right why
multi-dimensional profiling well the
reason one reason is well one big reason
is because every time i say i'm going to
build a profile everyone wants me to
build something that can look at edges
right the other reason is because
there's a lot of other stuff you can do
with a multi-dimensional profiler all
right you can look at which code is
being which code is using which memory
that's kind of interesting thing to look
at right in fact that's what this is
showing for GCC showing the hot regions
of which regions of code or touching
which regions of memory the adaptive
precision but you can also look at like
what code is using what values that's
kind of interesting thing why would you
do that well if you're finally for an
arm something or you're compiling for
something that requires a small amount
of bit width you care about that you can
look at which values are stored in which
ranges are men wearing all right you can
do this all the precision adaptively so
we've done some of these studies so big
problems we need to map be able to map
this data back to a software land right
this is all sort of in terms of
addresses and values but we want to
correspondent this with procedures and
in parameters so that's a big problem
that we're trying to work on right now
another big problem is if you're going
to deal with all this data and this is
true not just if this this work but in
general is that we need a good way to
visualize these things right you'll
notice that this is a map of code versus
memory but you'll also notice that this
is not a linear scale right because you
have a huge you know this is gigs of bet
we have like gigs of address space in
either direction right and if you
actually drew this to scale all you see
is one big box right and then the powers
of two powers of two powers up to you
know although interesting stuff is in
testimony small right so there's not
really way to see all these different
multiscale data in a nice way so you
know this is a nice little active thing
where we you know this distance here is
proportional to the square root of the
actual distance so you can actually see
all the data altogether
see what's going on um so getting back
to Mark's question marketer was that you
know there's a lot of opportunity we
think for exploiting more advanced
stream algorithms to do this stuff so we
have some ongoing work with them people
in algorithms to do this and using it
for optimization okay so now you can
escape sometime so the so in conclusion
you know we were working on basically
really high throughput analysis engines
right in this work applying it to
processor profiling so we have some work
already from a spots or building a
prototype based on fpga based system
doing streaming algorithms trying to do
that and hardware and taking that to be
multi-dimensional so oops misspelled it
so we're trying to just to recap or
trying to rethink computing with the
ability to see a full visibility all
right we want systems we can see through
essentially it's like x-ray goggles for
system to development so that we can
account for everything we can control
things we can adapt to their behavior
and we can optimize them and i also have
to give a very big thanks to these three
gentlemen here who are the students who
worked on all this stuff and did all the
hard work other than make slides and so
that's banat shashi and Mohit so if you
see them in a conference you know make
sure to say hello and ask them all the
hard questions and all the stuff all the
code that we develop is always available
online so feel free to go and use it
okay I think that's it
information your region that profiling
for example you can obtain some
information for static profiling or
instrumentation the figure out which
regions are interesting to put Congress
or associate counters with because we
have we have it actually no no we have
not we have nothing that and that is
interesting in fact oh so what one of
the things shot she's working on right
now is doing is sort of the first step
of that though which is just being able
to say maybe we don't want to divide
things up by powers of two boundaries
right because then you get counters on
kind of weird right it crosses to data
structures or crosses a procedure you
know what does the counter that like
that mean it makes more to to send to
someone who's actually looking at the
data if instead of adapting by powers of
two you adapt from you know full a full
library down to a file of that library
down to a procedure in that library down
to a loop of that you know so a basic
block and so on but the same idea still
still holds so trying to merge those two
day at first what's that that's right
that's right
yeah questions times the event
correlation um yeah don't ask that no
I'm joking uh so this doesn't yeah I
don't think this will well I should I
take that back so you it depends you
might be able to do that with
multi-dimensional profiling right so so
edge profiling is kind of like what
you're saying right and you know a
branch execute and it goes to a
particular location right so I mean
that's a that's a pretty easy
correlation to find but you can do that
with this oh yeah definitely yeah and
they're the Croatian seem that I'm fully
branded in time I feel exploit something
or just that's right yeah so there's a
lot of sort of path stuff but that's
interesting in that although with a lot
of the work that's been done here you
can take paths and quantify them as a
number right and so so now you can treat
that as a counting problem again so yeah
we don't you know I think there's a
there's a lot of noisy asses there's a
lot of potential to build really
interesting debugging tools and just
development and analysis tools that just
run a really high speed and you know we
can we can spend our time taking stuff
that people have already done and trying
to make it fast but you know what I'd
really like to see happen is to be able
to do things that people couldn't do
before you know so there are some really
high complexity analysis that and it
they necessarily involve static analysis
with dynamic analysis right to do
anything that's really heavy weight you
have to know something about what's
going on the program but like race
condition and
you know really heavy race condition
detection is an example of something
that's pretty heavy weight there's some
really heavy security mixed static
dynamic security propagation stuff which
you want to be able to do so yeah keeps
my grad students busy I suppose your
questions
alright thanks